man who isn't slumping is the man on the
mound top for the braves drew smiley's
really turned things around in braves
colors this year
and he puts it in play to short danesby
had him played perfectly the ground ball
out gets the day started for drew smiley
one away
and how about that smiley breezes
through the first inning one two three
the braves will take aim at the ageless
wonder rich hill when we come back
for the tampa bay rays today brought to
you by daycare rich hill 41 year old
left-hander
veteran and he just walked jack peterson
to lead off the braves first good start
for atlanta
really it's just freeman doing a great
job making contact on the ground out at
second over first safe there
freeman's aboard for ozzy albees
and ozzie launched it away deep right
center field kiermeier back that ball is
off the fence freddie's around third
they're gonna wave him here he comes
relay throw to the plate it's high all
the way to the back stop hill backs it
up and the braves take the lead on
another extra base hit from ozzy albee's
one-two pitch
is caught on and miss that bounced on
top of the plate six up six down for
smiley that's his fourth strikeout
hopeful and confident that
he'll be back bigger and better than
ever and he can't do any better than
drew smiley just did in the fourth
inning
and that's high for austin reilly that's
based on balls and that's how the fourth
inning starts second lead off walk
issued by hill
down to third
wendell goes to second out there and
over to first not gonna be in time no
balls in a strike
this one lined into center and votes got
his first hit as a brave
two on one out here's heredia who
doubled his first time
lined hard toward right a rosarina back
won't get back that's off the base of
the wall we got a relay race one run
will score it's another double for
heredia the o2
he does put it in
play and it's a race to the back and
smiley's gonna win it
braves have him loaded for jack peterson
a squibber back to the mound hill
knocked it down kicked it that'll cost
him a run
and lost this one into center field
tier meyer trying to measure his leap
and makes the catch as he makes contact
with the wall and hangs on to retire the
side
[Applause]
oh roller left side that's going to be a
basic
well he overloaded the right side
swanson the only man
on the left side
and he's swinging that's a fair ball
left side
loud's headed to third a little trouble
on the pickup there and the rays here in
the fifth inning come out swinging and
have two men in scoring position
into the dirt that ball is going to get
five vote the reigns are gonna get a run
wow comes home from third they are on
the board to make it three to one
and that's a shot back into right gonna
be caught
peterson makes the grab a tag
by zanino he scores coming home from
third
three balls two strikes
and a slow dribbler
tough play wendell bare hand and not in
time
chops it to short
bronco to second one
louder first for two
six four three and boy that makes a
pitching coast look good with one out
here's wander franco
that's a high drive back into center
moretti is going to go to the wall
good bye
home run to center off the bat of wander
franco his third home run of the year
and the rays
have tied this game 3-3
and a line drive by vote
he's got two hits today and another
leadoff man is on for the braves
one-on-one out and jeffrey springs
will get the call from the raised
bullpen and with two out
chuck peterson the batter
and that one served the other way a base
him the braves are back in front
peterson's chugging for two here comes
the throw it's late
put it in play boys and good things
happen atlanta four tampa bay three
round ball that's going to go through
into center field
for a base hit and now kevin kirmar
on the ground and that's through and the
right toward the corner got a chance to
score wendell peterson up with the ball
joey's gonna head to the plate and he
will score without a play kerber ties
this game and now it's austin meadows
against the lefty
[Applause]
dry ball into center here is going to
make the catch
keemer will tag and head to the plate
and the raise will take the lead
on the fly ball to center off the bat of
meadows
luke jackson on the hill
and he lines this one that's going to be
all the way back to the wall toward the
corner he'll dig for two
and we'll make it standing up with a
pinch hit double
so he's in scoring position for yandy
diaz
fly ball back to center here's going to
go all the way under the wall gone
home run to center off the bat of yandy
diaz
belting the home run
a two-run shot
the rays
make it a three-run game
with a four-run seventh
full count pitch
and a slow dribbler dansby charges has
to hurry
the beauty great play
and freeman shoots one to the right side
and overran
by lau
as again we await the 3-2 pitch and it's
served the other way and throw from base
hit freddie's around second he's on his
way to third so vote with two outs and
two on
line driving to center he's got three
hits
and the braves are down 7-5 now
he's got my vote
you saw pete fairbanks on the mound
that's one of the changes the rays make
as we go to the bottom of the ninth
3-2
and he gets him looking at the slider
at the knees to end this one